[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Applause]
[Music]
big massive dump
[Music]
big massive dumpster
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
big massive dumps huge dumps
were happening all over the country what
is going on here
big massive dump huge dumps
were happening all over the country what
is going on here
big massive dumps the fbi and department
of justice
i don't know maybe they're involved and
i'm sure you felt that way
that i'm sure you felt that way the fbi
and department of justice i don't know
maybe they're involved
they call them dumb big massive
[Music]
dumpsters
[Music]
all right we we're just too busy to even
do the entire thing and there's just too
much to talk about
so um earlier we had a live stream where
we heard from the incoming
biden communications team the future uh
director of white house communications
director and future
white house press secretary it was very
uncontroversial it was refreshingly
boring and we found out that next
a week joe biden will be receiving the
first dose of his coronavirus vaccine
now even though now you might say wait a
second david oh whoa whoa whoa whoa stop
the clock
trump's done nothing for weeks today his
only thing was a closed meeting
with the secretary of defense yesterday
was a close to press
signing of a women's suffrage monument
the day before it was a cabinet meeting
closed to the press
the day before he had nothing scheduled
whatsoever
the day before he had lunch with the
vice president and signed an executive
order closed to the press
the day before he played golf the day
before he went to the place at which he
would be playing golf
and did he actually play um
who knows what the hell was going on the
day before he had nothing scheduled
the day before he had two meetings okay
so all of this is going on and then you
look at the covet numbers
and you say wait a second yesterday 3
400 people died
and then you look at the day before and
you see the death numbers and you see
we're having a nine
more than a 9 11 every day you might
think oh we're going to see trump and
he's going to say something
important and as of right now
vice president pence there's rumor that
maybe trump will be here
is going to do a birthday party for
space farce
a birthday party for space farce is what
we're doing
today even though three thousand thirty
five hundred people
a day have been dying of covid and trump
has done
and said nothing about it um
i i guess people are probably right he
doesn't really
seem to care now i do have an
announcement to make i am considering
enrolling as a lieutenant
in space farce uh and my uh
my fiefdom will be an asteroid
uh yeah anyway i'm making if i might be
too old to enroll but if i am in
if i'm young enough to enroll in space
farce i plan to do it
um okay aquatic llamas wants a breakdown
of the opening montage
yeah that's it that's actually an idea i
i don't even know if i have
where do i have the source is it stream
intro compilation
is this oh yeah this is it yeah these
are just different
um i guess you would call them visual
elements
this is me with my juicer at home i have
trouble with my juicer it oftentimes
attacks me so that's why i'm being very
very careful with it
um the next clip is from
whoa uh the next clip is from when we
did some old old videos
at a club men's clothing store this is
like probably
12 years old in northampton
massachusetts when i lived in that part
of the country
these are just deep fakes i don't even
know who these musicians originally were
and who my face hasn't been swapped out
with
this is when i ripped up paper and
tossed it and a piece flew back and hit
me in the left ear right there and then
i had to tweak my ear
um this was more of the fitting i
believe this is called an ascot
can somebody correct that's me in my
garden i that's one of my huge peppers
and i try the tip of it and it's
pretty good as you can see every every
clip here has a story
i don't even know what this is but some
people liked it and sent it to me
this is me with my new helix beautiful
pause
my helix mattress that's a sponsor and
and we set up and and filmed me
testing it out and as you can imagine
that's the normal way to test the
mattress is you
this is how everybody tests it right
just like that boom um
this is during a caller that i couldn't
understand i was just perplexed
by what was going on
that's all that is this is from a long
time ago when i had to pick up producer
former producer lewis and bring him to
vote
because he was refusing to vote and we
filmed it
i waited outside of course and then he
had his i voted sticker
that's another test of my mattress
nothing no big deal
this is me further ahead in the testing
process of an ascot
that's me demonstrating the right way to
open a banana a lot of people open it
from the wrong end and you kind of mush
up
the banana if you open its stem end you
never want to open its stem
end
there you go that's me trying another
type of pepper in my garden
that one was a little spicy this is when
we had a jenga game over several days in
the old studio
anyway i don't think this is that
interesting but maybe someday i'll do a
full breakdown of every uh
every aspect of it uh okay john person
says i'm fine with any biden pick for
space force as long as they aren't
ferengi i believe that's a star trek
reference i'm not a star trek guy so
unfortunately i can't comment
uh okay now i did promise actually hold
on wait a second wait a second wait a
second i have a few different things
i did promise in the earlier stream that
i would play
i guess i would try to play parts of 15
consecutive voicemails i got from our
new caller
ree peter r e peter ree peter
um but i'll do that a little bit later
here is one from who we call the san
antonio troll though let me play this
one for you this is a voicemail that
came in
see what you think about this pac-man
i'm true i'm wondering why is it that
you
left us screaming from the rooftops
saying we need to shut down
everything everything needs to be shut
down so again this the san antonio troll
if he's known for anything it's calling
in and attacking me
over positions i've never taken and
um again i i have never said shut down
everything so
he just calls in and continually attacks
me for positions i've not espoused i
think he doesn't watch the show i think
he only calls
you don't go to work no one should go to
work so i've never said that either of
course
you guys all work from home you destiny
tyt
all you guys kyle's all you guys work
from home
so it's easy for you guys to say shut
everything down
i've never said shut everything down
when you're still making sixty thousand
dollars a month
sitting on your ass
you're reporting the news reporting you
shift it's already been reported
well no so again i never claim to be a
news reporter either i
we do commentary analysis and interviews
and we we in in fact i am so acutely
aware that we are not reporting news
that when i do a story
we link to our sources we analyze
and comment and react to news reported
by
others so that's what we call a lack of
media literacy
we're not doing reporting here easy for
you to say dude
really easy for you to say i'm so glad
workers okay
are actually which you guys are against
too you guys are against
worker protests we are i when have i
said i'm against protest that's a weird
thing this
maybe this guy thinks this is the number
to a different show
you'll see oh they just went here it's
not why people are protesting dude
this is exactly why the left you this
form of
your form of leftism isn't leftism it's
it's some kind of like grifting i don't
even know how to explain it
all you guys you all are not really left
you don't really care y'all just
it's funny he's criticizing the left and
saying we're not actually on the left
well then i'm on your side i guess by
that logic whatever's popular
is which are good people uh
this is why workers reject or rejecting
leftism
so actually the working class went more
anyway
i'm trying to talk about electoral
politics with someone who's you know
i mean it's just not a it's a waste of
time so
donald trump was right about one thing
america will
never be a socialist nation so i'm not a
socialist i don't know why you're coming
to me with that but obviously
a claim that something will never happen
in the future
by definition can't be right or wrong
that's like saying you will never win
the lottery
it's about a future event how do you how
it's not even a com
it's not even an assertion that we can
evaluate reason being
is because you guys are y'all y'all's
lost the left
you've lost as liberals and leftists by
being so anti-worker
liberals and leftists lost the left by
being anti-worker that's all pac-man
i know what upsets you but that's it
okay
anyway so that's an example of a uh
that's an example of a caller okay so
very very powerful caller
um ron says the space force isn't new
trump took an existing part of the air
force and made it a separate branch it's
still the department of the air force of
course
of course that's there's no question
about that big thank you
to the two new twitch subscribers
as we call them which puts us at
and i also want to say thanks to matthew
jeans
who subscribed at joinpakman.com nelson
kading and jan visic
which puts us at 37. my promise earlier
was
where we left off last stream which i
think was 31.32
we would pick it up today and we will
blow the phone lines wide open
if we get to 100 website members and
twitch subs by the end of the stream we
will go directly to the phones
after the space farce briefing so that's
something very very exciting
to get to get to and then what else did
i have here
um while i'm ready for politics to be
boring again says robert havens those
hatreds will keep me tuning in david
keep up the good work thank you robert i
appreciate that and i would love to hear
from you
via super chat as well okay um i've been
notified that there is a petition
for me to open and only fans i don't
know who
made this um let's see what it's
what's up with it david pakman from the
david pakman show to make and only fans
let's see us totally straight giga chads
who happen to be progressives want two
things
universal healthcare and david pakman's
only fans oh my god
i'm not trying to sell you anything just
facts
updates david package we want
feet picks and green mutil jesus christ
um oh my god
david's got more shimmy than a jive bug
yeah i don't um i mean listen uh 61
people
are not going to convince me um to open
and only fans and as i've said before
i have a cameo i have a cameo cameo i
believe is the work
safe only fans and i'm using that that's
what it is
um someone did call in
jacob is counting on you jacob needs
your help with david pakman to make an
only fans oh my god all right we've got
to get off of that that's just that's
that's toxic stuff
um anyway okay so that's that
and i am i don't i think only fans and
cameo would just be very uh duplicative
and we're not gonna do not duplicitous
duplicative is the word i'm looking for
toxicity high levels of toxicity okay
that's that
and then one other thing i had for you
guys if you want to see somebody living
in a complete and absolute fantasy world
this is donald trump's press secretary
and campaign advisor kaylee mcinanny
now you might think the electoral
college voted on monday it's over
no no no kaylee has an alternative
universe in which you can choose to live
take a listen to this
what is the update now that we're at
this late date in terms of the
challenges in other states and
investigations that are ongoing
right yeah there's still ongoing
litigation in arizona there are a few
other
appeal options in nevada and elsewhere
so the president's litigation is ongoing
make make no mistake
strongly also in the four states that we
saw a lot of problems in with those big
metro areas the only metro areas where
joe biden beat hillary clinton
ironically
in those states there has been an
alternate slate of electors voted upon
that congress will
decide in january so we will see what
happens ongoing litigation
so when she says i i i've actually been
getting emails from people
about this um alternate slate of
electors and so that what people think
is going
on and uh yes i am reading super chats
these are just i can see why that would
be confusing i am reading super chats
there's just
none up to read right now if you can
imagine something sad
so what they want you to believe and by
i want to be
specific when i say they what kaylee and
other people like you know um trump
maybe trump's lawyers just trumpists
what they want you to believe is
even though it seems as though in
georgia
democratic electors voted for joe biden
they assert
other electors republican electors also
voted for trump
and that it's going to be up to mike
pence to decide on january 6
do we count the biden electors or do we
count
the trump electors this is completely
farcical
okay and it's farcical for two reasons
number one
mike pence doesn't decide which electors
to count on january 6.
mike pence just oversees the counting of
electors there's only one set of
electors in each state
so when they say republican electors
also voted
and maybe those will be counted or maybe
not um
they're not actually electors like
republicans
presented people that they claimed to be
alternate electors
and they did something which they are
calling voting
it's as if i get myself and my neighbors
together in massachusetts and say you
know even though biden
won uh we are going to vote for
trump as an alternate set of electors
and mike pence can decide which ones to
take it's of no me it's of no value or
meaning whatsoever um
so kaylee is just lying or she's an
idiot
or both i mean it's they're not mutually
exclusive but
um it's not there's no alternate slate
of electors there's there's the electors
that voted
in state houses and that's it that
that's just
it and maybe they are um uh
maybe they're using this to continue
raising money i don't know
uh so people will keep donating to trump
to pay off his campaign debt it's it's
absolutely bizarre uh okay
johnny minogue says theory kaylee is one
maga character played by a set of twins
to fill both the white house and
campaign role allah mary kay
it's mary kate and ashley olsen that's
an idea
if trump existed in the star wars
universe which character do you think
he'd be oh jabba the hutt obviously i
mean what
what other is there even another
possibility
could there i mean other than job who
else could it be
um chris says in my fifth month as a
member totally worth it
tim guayne says he would be palpatine
for sure okay
can you compare this to hawaii 1960 with
nixon
i don't know enough about that i mean i
know that you know when trump said no
president has ever lost or won certain
states the the he seems to have
forgotten about 1960
uh nixon but i don't know enough about
it to be able to say more
uh do you know what rank pat is in
brazilian brazilian jiu jitsu if not can
you give him
the answer can you have him give the
answer on the bonus show
i believe that um
i believe that pat is supreme allied
commander in brazilian jiu jitsu is that
a rank
i could have sworn he said he was
supreme allied commander
but i may be misunderstanding odds of
republican states seceding
zero 0.0
um remember the red states depend on the
blue states paying money
into the federal government to subsidize
them
a red state country however you slice
and dice it like you could argue well
georgia is part of the red states or
it's not because they voted biden
you know what you can kind of debate the
edge cases the red state country that
would come from secession would be
completely financially unsustainable
it's an absolute
it's an absolute joke so it's not going
to happen
okay um thank you to
durgees who says i reject your reality
and substitute my own yes
that's exactly what kaylee is doing
appreciate the sub
barathamidu subscribes and says david
can you help sam
cedar get to a million subs on youtube
seems like a good holiday present i
don't know how i can help but i believe
sam is close
which is exciting also thanks to zinn
dragon hey david no memes to share hope
you have a good day
and thanks to treblag that puts us
with plus four puts us at 41
website members i will open the lines
the phone lines right after this space
farce event
if we get to a hundred okay we're at 41
strong start if we get to 100 a number
42
is damien hendrix who just signed up at
join pat i wonder if that's the damian
hendrix i know that's interesting
damien hendricks is new member number 42
please remember membership specials may
be
outlawed by the biden administration if
biden's going to outlaw
toilets that are high flow if biden's
going to outlaw
high flow shower heads if biden's going
to outlaw windows
if biden's going to outlaw air
conditioning in the summer
and indoor heating in the winter if
biden's going to outlaw what else was it
faucets high flow faucets and if biden
is going to require only dishwashers
that you have to run
three times he's certainly doing away
with my
extreme membership discounts okay so
this is the time to take advantage of it
you will be grandfathered
in and you can sign up in mir instance
at uh joinpakman.com with the coupon
code
fresh start uh biden will outlaw
summer to end global warming that's
exactly right
and the memberships are it's actually i
see people talking about hydrosonic
um what i learned from donald trump is
the memberships are both
hypersonic hyposonic
hydro sonic it's all of the above
which is insane if you know anything
about physics
um am i uh planning to cover the recent
cyber
incidents related to solar winds and
likely attribution to russian actors do
you consider it an act of war
act of war i i don't know i'm going to
talk about that on monday
i want to have a more informed opinion
and what's your thought on deb halland i
don't really know much about her to be
to be perfectly frank
that'll be a monday topic read this
somewhere is that true mcconnell is
withholding relief because of connection
to a nursing home mogul
i i mean i don't i don't know i've not
heard that
i've not heard that ben says what's your
favorite part of boston
probably um probably winter hill
actually i don't even know if winter
hill is part of boston it may be
it's winter hill and somerville which i
think i think somerville is not part of
boston now i don't remember
um okay we are standing by
for a trump administration birthday for
u.s
space force word is i am going to be
inducted as an honorary lieutenant
of space force uh by by mike pence
momentarily may the farce be with you
says david seeley yeah okay you since we
have a little time
let's just do this um
we have a caller who last week called me
six times in a row
saying the same thing every call okay
our friend jethro bradley did a song
about him we are calling him
repeater r.e hyphen peter and jethro is
just calling him the repeater
take a listen i have no name for this
caller
we could workshop a name together okay
here we go
so this started almost at the stroke of
midnight last night all right let's take
a listen to the first one this is a new
caller we've never had this one before
new caller alert is this david pac-man
i just want to inform you that is this
david pac-man
okay so jethro really quickly put
together that
that song this guy proceeded to call me
two nights ago
15 times in a row
15 times in a row can you imagine
let's just dig in and start listening to
it i i probably can't i can't do all of
this this is about an hour of voicemails
but
15 times in a row here we go this is to
david pac-man the gossip show i call you
the gossip
show because you gossip trump is right
ex-president obama he destroyed our
military
yes he did trump was right about that
let me say it again
ex president obama the worst president
we've ever had
he destroyed our military that so that
went on for two and a half minutes
seconds later he calls back again with
voicemail number two
i'm going to leave another message to
you david pac-man
um the gossip show because you do gossip
and i just have to voice my opinion to
you because you're an idiot
one of the biggest idiots i've ever seen
president x obama
did destroy our military that's a fact
president obama the ex-president was the
worst president we've ever had
so that's the second voicemail that went
on three minutes
here is the third voicemail left moments
later
david pac-man the gossip show
you are a idiot
that's that that was only a nine-second
voicemail then we go into voicemail
number four
david pac-man the gossip show
you know i don't i don't it's hard to
believe anyone
watches your show because it's hard to
believe that i agree with you
every day i'm like shocked anybody's
watching this sound bites from donald
trump and laura trump and
you play a piece of a sound bite of
something that they said said
and then you gossip about it i really
don't know how people
watch you i mean you you're one of the
most ignorant people
probably on the planet now this one's
funny because he actually timed out at
three minutes let's hear how he gets cut
off
saying i don't know what your last name
is david pokemon or pac-man or whatever
okay and so he that that just cut off
because he actually maxed out the
recording then he went into voicemail
number five
david pac-man the gossip show
i'll say this very clearly please
joe biden did not win the election and
there's over a hundred million people
that know that
and nothing and there isn't anything
that you can say that's 100
million no matter how much you gossip
over a sound
bite because that's what you do you take
so and then this one got cut off as well
let's listen to the cop don't act like a
guy you look like a female
[Laughter]
good grief david pac-man
okay so that one there's that then we
went into voicemail number six
well hold on a second that's the wrong
player voicemail number six same caller
dave at the gossip show i'm gonna just
give you a few things you're probably
you're probably not going to understand
this because i don't think you have the
intelligence
no it's good that he's called me 15
times to tell me the same thing it's
more likely i'll understand it that way
number one there was a truck driver that
was told to take ballots
ballots from one state to another state
that is against the law
we have ruby freeman on that video that
night count running the ballots through
those machines multiple times
that is against the law we have ruby
freeman going to another part of the
building that night showing us all the
ballots that she was going to put in
this into this computer that
didn't have uh address on it addresses
on it
that is against the law whoa i think
that's probably uh going to destroy
biden so
then we're going to voicemail number
seven
david pac-man the gossip show i'll say
it one more time
the night of that video when ruby
freeman was running ballast
okay so now we're taking an overview and
then that went on for three minutes
voicemail number eight
this is david the gossip show because
you gossip like a little girl you're
putting out false
information again because you're a
little girl
the reason the proud boys are so the
proud boys are showing up to these trump
rallies is be because people from black
lives matter and antifa they attack
trump supporters okay then it's
voicemail number nine
understand this is like this is hours of
this guy's time
david i'm gonna start calling you david
pokemon
i prefer david pokey maine i think
that's more appropriate
anyways let me say this again because
you you're an idiot
uh idiot proud show up to these trump
rallies it's because black lives matter
and antifa which they are a terrorist
group
right they start fights they burn down
things all right so that's voicemail
number nine
moving on now to voicemail number 10.
gave it the gossip show the prowl boys
this could be the same this could be
voicemail seven eight or nine but it's
actually number ten
i've been sho have been showing up at
these trump rallies because that black
lives matter
and antifa show up and they start fights
right
the other day at one of the trump
rallies it was a peaceful trump rally
okay that's number 10 then we go on to
number 11. we're getting to the end
this is for david the gossip show
we have information coming out of
arizona
they're seizing all the dominion
machines seizure
county big seizure either sunday or
monday we will find out that those
machines
flip votes way votes
and all kinds of good stuff so let me
say it again david
pac-man or whatever your name is his the
the energy level is a little bit lower i
see people in the chat i
i agree with you he seems to be slowing
down you're an idiot
i mean we're an hour in now in arizona
the county of maricopa they're gonna
seize all the dominion machines they're
going to do a forensic
audit yep they'll even bring a forensic
dentist to look really closely
um then we go on to voicemail number 12.
i'm going to repeat myself one more time
david
oh that's gold he he's letting me know
he's going to repeat himself we're on
voicemail 12.
the gossip show in arizona
in the county of maricopa they are
seizing
all the dominion machines all right
that's number 12.
then we go to voicemail number 13.
david this is david the gossip show
what's really funny about you is you
never you don't
ever talk about anything that's factual
right
like ruby breebsen or something who
stole
trucks or something and then dominion
maricopa
you pull up sound bites and then you
gossip about it
kind of like this voicemail you really
belong in a dress in some high heels
and some lipstick you act just like a
little girl bro
high hills like i should live in the
hills he's saying
you don't ever talk about anything
that's factual on your show you pull up
sound bites about who's arguing about
you pull all right and then this is
winding down i apologize
we're down now this is voicemail 14.
david the gossip show you really don't
know how stupid
you actually look when you when you talk
about someone tweeting
something about someone else you've got
to be kidding me right
you actually talk about sound bites of
people
saying something about this guy might be
flirting with me i'm starting to think
guys and then here is voicemail number
15 the last one
hey everyone it's david the gossip show
gossip gossip gossip
you know i hate to call i hate to call
you some i don't i hate to call you
this much but that's weird because he
seems to be enjoying it there's no
indication
and who by the way who's forcing him to
call me 15 times really funny
to watch your little thing on youtube i
mean
you it's you pull up a sound bite or you
pull up a tweet from someone
and you gossip about it it's so i mean
it's really funny oh it is funny i mean
you really don't know how stupid you
look bro
you're you're you're an idiot i mean
there's no other way to put it
gossip gossip gossip
man isn't that insane like you know i i
i don't even know what to tell you um
just out of curiosity because these were
coming in so fast and furious
i'm gonna i just want to see if he left
more
while i was playing those um
it doesn't look like it i'm just
checking out
let me see here oh i think i think while
we were doing those i think troy york
called in it just it's never ending like
the you know how at a certain point
so there's this thing about how like
every minute
you know a hundred thousand minutes of
video are uploaded to youtube
so like you know you couldn't possibly
watch every youtube video
i feel like every minute that i play an
insane voicemail
two minutes worth of insane voicemails
are left let's listen to this
yeah i just wanted to tell you so this
is troy york just this is this is hot
off the press
yeah i listened to your program about
chris christie
your seven minute video i just want to
say you know it's just
more complete mask stupidity on your
part
the the dumbness of you thinking that
masks
somehow will slow down the spread and
that people are not wearing masks
it's sort of physics right in fact
everywhere you go if people are wearing
masks
you can't not wear a mask going into the
store so i don't know what the [ __ ]
what if you expect people having 24
hours or
driving alone in the car yeah you don't
need a mask i mean
this is the guy who asked why i'm not
wearing a mask when i'm live streaming
like i'm in a room by myself but do you
understand the point of masks
what exactly is your cycle you and the
left and your psychologists on
what's a psycholopsis you know saying
that masks stop viruses is like
the equivalent of of saying that wearing
a hat is going to stop baldness or
or wearing a hat will prevent dandruff
it's just absolutely astonishing
ooh that's very very dumb analogy and
then one more from the same guy
like fauci and christy are in brussels
probably corrupt he was a corrupt
politician
and why anything that he should say
should matter is a joke
and this is all basically the far left
progression oh boy now people
more people are calling in democrat
parties all right well i gotta get off
of that all right
we're gone anyway that's what's going on
there isn't that insane it's completely
bonkers
david l pokemane show is my favorite
gossip show of all time says captain
crunch
that caller is a damn loon he needs
mental help he so badly wants to see you
in a dress he has fantasies about you
obviously
rupert murdoch got the covet vaccine
today while fox news hosts
continue to spread doubt and fear about
vaccine safety
hi i'm how am i supposed to emphasize
empathize and be comrades with the
millions of people like that crazy
caller is this country beyond repair
i worry i worry that it is yeah i think
repeater has a crush on you says owen
can you explain why little little girls
are prone to spreading misinformation
yeah that is interesting he calls and
says
i'm like a little girl in gossiping and
spreading dis misinformation
i didn't know that the nexus of
disinformation was little girls
that's interesting love david pokemon
pacman's gossip show
thoughts on former israeli space
security chiefs comments about
governments being in contact with aliens
i i mean i find it difficult to believe
i find it difficult to believe that's
about all i can say
uh thank you to heavy metal mania
for the twitch sub which puts us at
43 remember we opened the phones at 100
after the event
also a few people signed up on my
website that i want to thank
jesus hernandez is new member number 44.
martin harisco is number 45. elliott
stock
is number 46. alan vue is 47
and joey fleming is new member number
48.
i see uh copious comments about opening
the phones
after this event um and we have a goal
of a hundred
website members and twitch subs that's
the goal
and we are about halfway there which i
think is
really really great people asking me to
comment about the
um ayoke jimmy dore controversy some of
you may know it as the aoc jimmy dore
controversy i actually got a call about
this on today so we did
calls for the friday show and people
asked me about it
and i was not on twitter over the
weekend and i don't watch
shows like you know jimmy dora or other
shows
so i didn't really know about it but my
understanding of the con
correct me if i'm wrong chat the con as
i understand the controversy
um jimmy dore wants aoc
and the squad to force a vote about
medicare for all
to force nancy pelosi to have a vote
about medicare for all
if they want if she wants them to vote
for her for speaker
and aoc i guess is unsure whether that
makes any sense
is am i correctly understanding the
controversy can somebody explain
nobody knows oh pretty much that's the
idea yeah so my thought was the
following
um right now i don't know that that does
anything for
people like people need money
high unemployment economic devastation
3 500 people dying every day i get the
idea of
hey let's get every member of the house
on the record
you're either for medicare for all or
you're not um but it seems to me
sort of like a waste of time in the
sense that
obviously we're not getting medicare for
all anytime soon
particularly i mean you know it's just
not happening at least in the next six
weeks
we may actually be able to do things
that help people in the next six weeks
so
i like the idea of holding nancy pelosi
to account and trying to get
something if she wants the votes of the
squad
at the same time i don't know that she
needs the votes of the squad to be
speaker of the house
um but it strikes me as a sort of
opportunity for virtue signaling like
aoc and the squad saying we won't vote
for nancy unless
we put up a medicare for all to a vote
which is not going to become the law
okay uh it seems sort of like it would
be virtue signaling
by the squad um and then
saying we're gonna we're gonna ostracize
those who don't vote for medicare for
all
again given that it's not actually going
to pass it also even seems like the
votes would be virtue signaling so
i i don't know it seems ego-based um
and i you know we need to fix health
care obviously
we've got to get people money there's a
lot of things we have to do
i i just don't know what we gain from
doing what jimmy dore
wants aeoc to do i just i just don't i
just don't see it
but that's my understanding of the uh
controversy
and i'm only hearing about it like third
hand really
because i don't watch any of these shows
alberto
segade is new member number 49 today
and madeline wiltshire is new member
number 50.
very much appreciate that also want to
say thanks to the
five folks who just grabbed twitch subs
uh dallas jones e sizzle morzov
sacred light and bonobo
and lastly dumped trumpet dumped
trumpet whoa i just grabbed a membership
on my website which puts us at 56
and uh i'm i'm not opening the phone
lines right now
but after the space farce event we will
open them
uh we are hold on 56 out of 100 let me
figure out the percentage
um five four ten point five ten carry
the zero uh one six
fifty six minus zero ten by four we are
fifty six percent of the way to one
hundred
which is where we will uh open the phone
lines alvaro says hey pacman on an older
stream
you mentioned the barclays center in
brooklyn as your old stomping grounds
what was your neighborhood fort greene
no i lived in um i lived sort of on the
line between
uh borum hill downtown brooklyn
and brooklyn heights there's a little
area there where i think it was called
i think the restaurant is 282 burger if
i recall correctly
or was it 8 808 burger something like oh
my god you can't i can't this is crazy
um i lived in that neighborhood in uh
in brooklyn beautiful beautiful
neighborhood who's my favorite drummer
oh there's just so many i mean everybody
from steve gadd and vinnie calauda
oh god this is real propaganda
um there's so many great drummers carter
beauford
and um you know it's just endless
endless endless i can't tell if space
force is part of the uh empire
or part of the um oh no what what are
the two
sides in uh in star wars
it's the empire and the how am i
blanking on this
not the coalition the um oh my god
the rebels oh my god yeah i can't tell
if space farce would be
on the side of the empire or on the side
of the rebels
uh i i really don't know all right let's
enjoy
i actually think this would be better
with one of our songs
i think it makes more sense with uh i
think it makes more sense with
jesus from south america they're coming
here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of
[Music]
okay anyway let's actually try to take
it seriously
as seriously as it deserves to be taken
what does this have to do with space
farce
[Music]
[Music]
relay star characterized
[Music]
oh this can't be for real
i think i have the snl feed accidentally
two one zero and liftoff
wasn't that spacex what did that have to
do with trump's space force
halos
don't a lot of these accomplishments
actually have to do more with african
immigrant elon musk than with space
farce
[Music]
oh my god oh this is too much
[Music]
people are clapping at the propaganda
this is this is indistinguishable from
parody
is trump going to be here i can't even
tell i guess that's the vp's
thing
i can't believe this is real
most of the accomplishments they're
taking credit for have to do with either
other countries or
elon musk
is south africa an s whole country and
maybe not because there's more white
people maybe trump wouldn't i mean it is
africa which i think trump
puts under that umbrella but there are
more white people
what a weird event i can't believe it
ladies and gentlemen
please welcome general jay raymond
acting secretary of defense christopher
miller
yeah secretary of the air force barbara
barrett
and the vice president of the united
states mike pence
what is the stranger things rip off
music imagine a standing ovation oh i
guess they stand because he's the vice
president okay
weird when you look at our coveted
numbers you start to wonder where are we
casting stones about [ __ ] countries
since the dawn of the space age the
united states has long understood
that access to space and freedom to
maneuver
in space underwrites our economy our
passion for science and exploration
and our national security yeah
recognizing that this vital national
interest could no longer be taken for
granted
the united states elevated space inside
the department of defense
to a level commensurate with its
importance to our nation
just a year ago on 20 december 2019
at a hangar at andrews air force base
the president signed into law
the national defense authorization act
which is the birth certificate
which this year he's going to veto
my god pence
and and what what a first year it has
been
the men and women of the space force
have written
an impressive very impressive first
chapter of our history
and i couldn't be more proud of them so
on behalf of all of the space
professionals
in the united states space force i want
to thank president trump
vice president pence and congress
for establishing this force in every
sector of space
america is leading and because of that
our nation is more secure
pence leading every applause line
they're they're laughing at us globally
about this right
special thanks to vice president pence
for hosting the
today's ceremony sir we can't thank you
enough
[Applause]
i also want to thank secretary miller
secretary barrett
general miller general heighton for your
trust and confidence
and for the privilege the absolute
privilege of serving alongside
the men and women of the united states
space force
each american armed service traces its
origin
to a critical moment in our nation's
history
our army navy and marine corps were
established in the crucible of america's
revolutionary war
the air force became an independent
service after the allied victory in
world war ii
as america steeled itself for a new cold
war and with the re-emergence
of great power competition in all
domains the nation established
the united states space force while each
service's culture and mission are
distinct
what is common between us is the war
fighting spirit
and commitment to victory embraced by
america's treasure
it's all volunteer force the members of
the space force are no different
we come to work every day focused on the
great responsibility
we've been given to custom build this
force to compete
deter and to win that requires talking
about the boldness
of colonel's casey beard and christopher
ningal
who led a team that built the first
space force doctrine the in first
independent
uh space power doctor it requires the
agility and innovation democracy we have
a space force but they're not sure they
can give people 600 bucks after
seven months for kovid for space and
embedded that software on the ops floor
improving our ability to have space
domain awareness
and it's the commitment to victory
displayed by captain tasia reed
and lieutenant christiana castaneda
whose mission planning ensured the
successful detection
of iranian missiles and preserve the
lives of u.s personnel
and our partner forces right people in
flint are still drinking bottled water
and we have a space force
very good point force that we built i
know they will deliver on the solemn
promise we've made to protect
and defend this nation against all
enemies foreign and domestic
with a war fighting spirit and our
touchstone traits of agility
innovation and boldness on the occasion
of our first birthday
i thank you all for your visionary
leadership and your enduring support
we have made history together and
looking back i'm confident
we will stand in awe of our efforts to
ensure the united states space force
and the united states is always above
happy first birthday
in semper supra
okay
ladies and gentlemen it is uh my
distinct honor
to introduce our secretary of the air
force barbara barrett
you know this has been a a pretty easy
job when you have a secretary of the air
force that cares so much about what you
do
and has made the next yeah do you do you
guys think that those people who have
lost their jobs
and may not even get any more money from
the government
do you think that they are satisfied by
seeing that we have space force at least
comforted maybe thank you general
raymond what a pleasure it is
to be a part of a team headed by
the leadership of general j raymond call
him hap raymond but
it's a it's an air force thing
you know for millennia humanity has
turned its gaze to the stars
for inspiration today we celebrate the
nation's
newest service dedicated to protecting
free and data
access i've never heard that high ground
for all benevolent
actors with the leadership of president
trump
the coordination cooperation with
congress
on bipartisan and bipartisan effort
the clear vision of a service was
established
to protect the american way of life and
it was launched
under the name of the united states
space force
no one has been a better champion of
that effort
than our vice president mike pence
pence was reportedly spotted uh taking
shots at the mos
eisley tavern with no mask before this
event united states military services
were established
when george washington was president
then technology opened two new domains
yesterday we celebrated the first flight
by wilbur and orville wright a flight
that
laid the cornerstone for the u.s air
force and today we celebrate the
protection of space assets by
the new u.s space force in its first
year
you might have expected a space force to
build a new headquarters
leadership team maybe to publish
planning guidance
maybe to transfer 2500 airmen from the
united states air force into the space
force
this is amazing you might have thought
that they would be able to establish a
force multiplier program
to generate a digitally fluent space
force
the space force in fact did all of that
but because of the bold leadership
of jay raymond and his team the space
force
also detected incoming missiles
in iraq five days after the elimination
of solamani
and and ultimately saved a great number
of american lives
homeless people will be very well
protected by space
force up in the sky they'll still be
homeless but they'll be protected by
space force
five eyes partners as well as france and
germany
the space force anticipated
international space station collision
risk
with space to space debris and the iss
maneuver to avoid that risk
ensuring the safety of our astronauts
and the space station
and for the first time in nearly a
decade the united states space force
supported
the launch of american astronauts from
american soil
on an american space capsule and so why
does this matter
well it matters because that's what i'm
wondering every american
uses space often without knowing it
uses space space controls our water our
power and our banking
space powers our information navigation
and communication
systems whether you're an eastern
urbanite or a midwestern farmer
or a hiker in the high sierras you're
probably using space
space taking up space i understand
all benevolent actors
today we salute the vision of the united
states space
yeah the very i admit to using gravity
that i do think i'm using
force is defending the ultimate high
ground
for our nation semper supra
this is indistinguishable from parody
and now let me introduce and
invite you to welcome the secretary the
acting secretary of defense chris miller
who draws on myriad experiences both now
this is the guy who's in only because
um wait why why is this guy because mark
esper resigned right am i
it's hard to even keep track of the
quittings and the firings and stuff
great job
don't tell anybody my only dream when i
was growing up
was to join the air force and become an
astronaut
and uh clearly my parents cursed me with
bad jeans and i had to get these things
disqualifying me but today i'm i had to
end up
going into the army and being a ground
pounder but today you'll know this is
really demoralizing air force socks
to me do not tell anyone in the army
they'll think i'm a heretic
[Laughter]
i hope there's not an ethics violation
here but i'm ready for some space for
socks whenever they come out we'll make
sure they get routed
oh my god is anybody else
cringing man what an incredible day
i'm humbled and beyond words to be able
to be part of this
secretary barrett vice chairman heighten
general raymond
family welcome what a day what an
historic day
many other leaders here today i'm trying
to understand like it it is the one year
anniversary of space force and space
force was made possible by trump signing
ndaa a year ago
but trump's about to veto ndaa so like
what
does do these things fit together in any
way following these great leaders
uh very special thank you thanks to
president trump vice president pence
as well they spearheaded this effort
truly an historic effort
sixth branch of the united states armed
forces one year ago today
you know when i was a kid uh i told you
when
somebody would go what do you want to be
when you grow up i was i grew up in the
70s
what did you say i want to be an
astronaut
my son's 19 he grew up in the 2000s and
when i'd asked him you know hey what do
you want to be when you grow up i get
all sorts of wacky stuff about i want to
be a baseball player
lacrosse player you know broke my heart
you know because
right that's where our country had come
to with our our space
don't in in the space domain and you
know
because of you all our sons and our
daughters now
when they're asked what do you want to
be when you grow up
guess what they're going to say again
astronaut
what is he talking about
this administration's bold decision to
create
the first new service in over 70 years i
love that
hap what the heck that what a great
what a great description and uh you know
to talk about the historical i don't
know who this guy is
but he is incredibly entertaining you
know
i know you're just nodding your head
that's not but that's really so telling
and so remarkable in first
you know service in 70 years you know it
really marked an important step forward
in deterring the threats posed by our
strategic competitors
ones that extend beyond traditional
warfighting domains
it was necessary to step in this area
it was it was a necessary step in this
area
this is one of the most entertaining
events we really need this comic relief
because we've had nothing like this for
months
that put our satellites and space-based
systems at risk
and it was a recognition of the
importance of securing freedom
of operation in what is now a highly
contested environment
space true to the motto of
semper supra our men and women in
uniform have already taken the space
force
to new heights in an incredibly short
time
general raymond noted publishing the
service's first space power doctrine
earlier this year and establishing
space operations command to commission
86 graduates 86 graduates came out of
the air force academy this year
uh in launching uh their careers into
the space force jeff daniels will play
this guy on snl what do you guys think
about launching uh the services first
as well and just last week the first
group of directly
enlisted space professionals celebrated
their graduation
from basic military training one of the
absolute joys i've had in this job
is signing commissioning recommendations
moving officers from the united states
air force
space force you know again that was just
uh a humbling humbling event as our
strategic competitors weaponized the
space domain through the development
anti-satellite missiles directed energy
weapons
and other counter space technologies our
personnel will lead the way
in preserving freedom of use commerce
and navigation into this guy will be
played by boris johnson on snl how about
that
much like nasa pioneered a new
generation of technologies in the 20th
century
our space professionals will be the ones
fostering
cutting edge innovation that will
protect our advantages
across every domain the decades ahead
and they will be the ones to ensure that
the united states is ready to defend our
assets in space
to stand up for freedom of navigation in
the shared domain
and ultimately to win any future
conflict
the great strides made by the space
force have been made possible thanks to
the bipartisan support of congress
the hard work of our service members
that was highlighted earlier civilians
and let's not forget at our contracted
workforce which is truly
one of our competitive advantages and
the leadership
of general raymond both as commander of
u.s space command
and as the first chief of space
operations
kind of a great title just saying
additionally we are incredible i've
expressed my concerns about
uh lloyd austin as secretary of defense
and they're numerous
but the presence of this guy
versus lloyd austin who will be working
for biden like politics aside
it's it's it's cartoonish the the the
contrast is
stunning uh his advocacy
on behalf of our armed forces and i see
most people don't see this regularly i
see it
all the time the leadership of the vice
president
his care and his compassion for our men
and women
in uniform and their families is
remarkable
uh your advocacy on behalf of our armed
forces and a new generation of space
professionals continues to make us
stronger
safer and more secure as we maintain
american superiority
in the ultimate high ground mr vice
president i'm going off script again
i know but uh i just want to personally
thank you
right uh if he could cry it would be
great
we've gone through uh some incre some of
the most complex military operations
this country's ever conducted
and your steady hand and your leadership
during those
was a great source of strength for me
thank you for your leadership thank you
for your character
thank you for your selfless service
thank you for commitment
thank you for being a mentor to me mr
vice president and with that
the floor is yours sir oh my god
that was historic in some way i don't
know exactly what way but
oh and pence gets his own podium of
course
[Applause]
well thank you all for lectern sorry uh
acting secretary of defense
chris miller to the secretary of the air
force barbara barrett
to uh general john highton general j
raymond
general james dickinson general david
thompson and general
general david alvin
on behalf of the first family
welcome to the white house and welcome
to the first anniversary
of that branch of our armed forces that
will ensure
for generations that america remains as
dominant
in space as we are on land and see
welcome to the first anniversary of the
united states space force
oh my god if we start spreading
democracy to space i think space is
screwed
many kind things haven't said about your
vice president but i have to tell you
i am the second biggest champion
of the space force behind this
administration so as we begin allow me
to bring greetings
and first anniversary congratulations
from a champion of everyone who wears
the uniform of the united states and the
founder
of the united states space force i bring
greetings and congratulations
from the 45th president of the united
states president donald trump
[Applause]
and by the way where has he been the
last three weeks three weeks
i just we just left the oval office with
the president and
uh from the very first moment that he
conceived of the idea
of creating a new branch of our armed
forces dedicated to our security in
space
this is feeling like scientology where
even like you you always have to make
sure you're giving all praise
to trump no matter what you're doing
here has only grown
in the last year and he's proud of each
and every one of you as i am
but we're grateful to the contributions
of all of you in this room
and to the speakers who have prescribed
this podium
for bringing us to the fruition of this
first trump who you will not be seeing
ever again is really pleased that we're
doing this right now
it saw the creation of the first new
branch of our armed forces in more than
70 years
uh and there are members of congress who
are with us today who i remember
in those uh critical moments in the
legislative process who were absolutely
indispensable and i'd like you to join
me in thanking
congressman doug lambert for your great
leadership
on behalf of our space board
and the first person ever to mention to
me that we ought to restart the national
space council
even before i had this job he is one of
the greatest champions of american
leadership in space
in the congress of the united states
congressman
brian babbin thank you
and i want to give particular note to a
member of the united states senate
who in the late going was there fighting
to ensure that we would establish
a new branch of our armed forces they
would have a fight it's kind of
depressing because there's few things
more interesting than space
travel and space exploration and this
administration has made it for lack of a
better term a complete and total farce
for your outstanding and seminal
leadership
i also want to take a moment to express
my appreciation to two members of
congress who are not here
but who have been and remain champions
and emblematic of the bipartisan support
that this new branch of our armed forces
enjoys across the congress of the united
states
join me in thanking congressman adam
smith
the chairman of the house armed services
committee right and the incoming
ranking member of the house armed
services committee
congressman mike rogers two leaders who
have championed
the united states space force strong
champions and it's my greatest honor to
be here with so many warriors
who have stood in the gap for america
and to be able to thank you for your
service
and to uh and to thank you for the
foundation that you've helped
pour for future generations of americans
in our security in space
there are several people to thank but i
there's a man who i consider to be a
giant
in the realm of american leadership in
space
he's a former commander of the air force
space command
i first i first met him at offutt air
force base
when he was leading our strategic
command forces there
he actually comes from a family that's
been involved in
american space enterprise throughout his
life and at just the right time
he became vice chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff would you join me in
thanking
general john heighten and his wonderful
wife laura
i thought he was actually the grand moff
of the rebel forces i didn't realize i
had his rank mixed up i think
i know the president knows is what i
knows we wouldn't be here without you
general so thank you
so very much for your strong leadership
but to all the members of our armed
forces with us here today thank you for
your service
and to our great nation and thank you
for your enthusiastic
participation in this first year of the
launch of the united states space force
you know yesterday marked the birthday
of flight
history records that it was 117 years
ago
that two sons of a heartland preacher
one of whom was born in indiana
did what uh for all of history it seemed
impossible when they
they took their first flight to the
skies over kitty hawk
but in just a few short days on sunday
december the 20th we will mark
the formal anniversary of another
american
breakthrough one month until he leaves
today it will
since president donald trump signed into
law the first new branch of our armed
forces
in more than 70 years that historic
moment
was a culmination of an effort that
began from the early days of this
administration from almost the first
moment
that the president and i spoke about
space when we were campaigning for these
jobs
he had a dual focus of renewing american
leadership in human space exploration
imagine if instead of a propaganda event
pence showed up and announced we figured
out faster than light travel or
something completely insane i mean
none of us would even believe it these
people are so incompetent president
trump called forth
steps to renew american leadership in
space it would be in june of 2018
the president first laid out a vision
that called for the creation of a new
military service
focused solely on threats in and from
space
the idea though and its conception was
not a new one
for more than 50 years presidents and
military leaders had discussed a branch
of our military
dedicated to ensuring american national
security
in and from space but time and again
those
efforts faltered but i would submit to
you
that it is a tribute to the leadership
of our commander-in-chief
a tribute to the extraordinary military
leadership gathered here today
that this time with bipartisan support
in just one and a half years the united
states space force was born
right and since that historic moment the
united states space force has only grown
stronger by the day
and that means that america has grown
more secure
by the day after the space force became
law the president's first decision was
who would lead it
and the president and i get the sense in
the room
there is broad agreement that he got
that decision right too
he chose a man
he chose a man who you've heard from
these podiums already
is considered to be the half arnold of
our time
he would become the chief of space
operations of the united states
space force and i can tell you having
witnessed his leadership firsthand
that when general j raymond uh stepped
forward
uh it brought the leadership the energy
the vision the profession did i miss it
or did they did they outline
exactly what space force has done that
has made us so safe or did i miss that
part
space force so join me in thanking
general jay raymond his wonderful wife
molly and his proud son gary for all of
their commitment to america
thank you general great job
what the hell
[Applause]
it's amazing oh the clips before the
event were the accomplishments i see
general raymond actually welcomed the
first enlisted member to the space force
so
how about a round of applause for chief
master sergeant roger
tauberman
you can stand up come on stand up
thank you i'm i'm really cringing here
thank you chief in april those two men
were literally the entire united states
space force
but in just eight months we already have
more than two thousand military members
space professionals in space in the
united states space force and i'm told
in an additional 3
600 officers and enlisted airmen
have already started to fill out the
paperwork to transfer into the space
force
fact general raymond tells us that we
anticipate on our current trajectory the
space force will have nearly 6 000
space professionals serving all across
the globe
in just a short period of time what do
they do in fact today the space force
got its newest and perhaps most famous
member oh no
a man who is actually in space right now
at the international space station
general take care of the paperwork
and i think it might actually be the
first
in-orbit transfer in military history
colonel michael hopkins nasa
astronaut and member of the united
states space force
you know heroes like him and like all of
you are going to inspire
generations of americans yeah in fact uh
secretary barbara barrett and i
witnessed some of those young americans
stepping forward at a
in colorado springs where we both had
the opportunity to address the 60-second
graduation of the united states air
force academy
when i was there they told me in a
typical year about 20 cadets
choose to go into space operations
this year i was there when 86
cadets stood up and took the oath as
officers in the united states space
force
right
and just to continue to build on the
momentum i'm proud to report to
the senator and these members of
congress and all those looking on that
it was
my honor with secretary barrett at my
side
and general raymond as well that we made
it official
we traveled to florida to announce the
first two space force
installations in american history cape
canaveral space
force station and patrick space force
base
yeah but can we get 600 bucks to people
for the covet stimulus
and the space force is growing stronger
every day
and just in the nick of time i think
every one of the military leaders here
knows that space
is a vacuum but we're not operating in a
vacuum
the space race began in the 1950s and it
continues today
and in president donald trump we have a
commander-in-chief who's understood
clearly that space is a war fighting
domain
it's imperative that we invest
the resources and the personnel and the
technology
to defend our nation and defend our
values in the outer reaches of space
in fact the united states as you've
heard already faces emerging threats in
space for countries like
china and russia and those threats are
only growing
we're reminded of that just this week
when russia conducted yet another
anti-satellite
missile launch we're leading in space
but our determination under this
president
and with his extraordinary military
leadership is to stay
in the lead to defend america and defend
our freedom from space
we seek peace through strength and i
want to say to the men and women of the
united states space force
when it comes to the outer reaches of
space you are that strength
so today we celebrate leadership
from our president to great bipartisan
support in the congress
and the military leadership that is seen
to both the birth
and the pouring of the first years
foundation of the united states space
force
and i just came here today to thank each
and every one of you
but also to make another announcement
as i mentioned we just returned from the
oval office and so
it is my honor on behalf of the
president of the united states
to announce that henceforth the men and
women of the united states
space force will be known as guardians
oh no
no it can't be
the guardians of the galaxy
oh my god kill me
it can't be it can't be
this is when the united states jumped
the shark right marines
and guardians will be defending our
nation for generations to come
are you an airman sir no i'm a guardian
so with that announcement let me just
say thank you again
i want to thank the the members of
congress who are with us today
thank you for the honor of your presence
but more importantly thank you we don't
deserve a country
thank you for your leadership in
bringing us to this moment one
year ago and the support that you've
continued to provide
i succeeded the launch of this new
branch of our armed forces
oh my god on behalf of your
commander-in-chief let me urge each and
every one of you
guardians to keep pushing
he's pretending it's real it's serious
keep pushing
keep pushing the vision and the mission
of the united states space force which
is to ensure that america remains as
dominant
in space and from space
as we are on land and sea and air
and to each one of you guardians let me
just say
each and every day from this day forward
i want to assure you
that you will serve with the confidence
of your commander chief
you will serve with confidence and
gratitude of the american people
and i'm also convinced that those of you
that will serve in the united states
space force
in this generation and generations to
come
we'll also go with the prayers of
millions of americans
who will claim that ancient verse that
promises that if you rise on the wings
of the dawn
if you settle on the far side of the sea
even if you go
up to the heavens what the hell
that there his hand will guide you
and his right hand will hold you fast
what
that then will be our prayer for our
guardians in this generation
and for generations to come so happy
birthday
to the united states space force god
bless our guardians
god bless all the members of our armed
forces
and god bless america
this is one of the dumbest things i've
ever seen i mean this is humiliating
this is humiliating
[Applause]
was that a prayer to space jesus
[Applause]
oh my god dude where's your mask too
you know what i have to admit biden
could never do that
but by there there is no way in hell
that with a straight face joe biden
would be able
to do something so idiotic and so
cringe-worthy
it's like he's he's marginally too
self-aware to ever be able to accomplish
what mike pence just
uh just just accomplished um
i don't even i mean it's
i've never seen anything like it um
yeah i see if people want to do some
memes where
with the tr with pence announcing it in
my reaction or if you want to clip that
or do anything you can any materials you
can get me
related to that moment please uh submit
them through the website contact form
um i i can't believe what we just saw
it's it's just outrageous it's
completely outrageous
um and disturbing in a lot of ways too i
mean it's just just idiotic
anyway um that's gonna do it for me make
sure
you are uh subscribed for free on
youtube we are
just we're probably a few hours from 1.2
million subs
on youtube it's insane uh make sure you
follow me on uh
on twitch make sure you give us a like
on facebook and i will be back
what a sad day i mean just a humiliating
humiliating day i will be back
um at some point soon
maybe to uh play us out we'll come up
with something
a little bit you know a little bit
upbeat
that will make us feel a little bit
better maybe uh maybe the rudy giuliani
fart song would help us a little bit
i don't know anyway i'll see you guys
very soon
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
there's
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
i'd say that pole buff is off by over a
hundred thousand
that poll books why don't you look at
the registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on
[Music]
120